bienvenidos a barrow alaska la ciudad
más al norte del mundo también es
conocida por su nombre y muy edward peak
el paquete de bacon por esta tierra
cuesta 15 dólares un pequeño saco de
harina sale por 20 dólares y una bolsa
de pan de molde cuesta 6 dólares el
suelo está congelado durante la mayor
parte del año así que las casas no
pueden tener cimientos tampoco hay
carreteras que conecten esta ciudad así
que la única forma de llegar es por
avioneta o el trineo a estas alturas la
gran pregunta que muchos estaréis
haciendo es cómo es posible que haya
5000 personas viviendo por aquí quién
vendría a vivir a un lugar así en
general quién querría vivir en un estado
como alaska y a la vez porque es un
estado tan importante para eeuu al final
de este vídeo entenderéis por qué alaska
es uno de los estados más ricos de todo
el país y a la vez porque sufre una de
las crisis financieras más terribles del
país
vamos con ello
[Aplausos]
[Música]
alaska es el estado más grande de eeuu
al menos en lo que a territorio respecta
ahora bien tienen menos de un millón de
habitantes apenas hay carreteras y casi
todo el transporte se realiza por avión
de hecho tiene una de las tasas más
altas de pilotos de avión per cápita de
todo el mundo
[Música]
y qué me decís de que inhalas que hace
tanto frío que hasta los de burgos se
tienen que poner un abrigo vale esta
broma solo lo entenderéis los de españa
en invierno las temperaturas pueden
alcanzar los 40 grados bajo cero y
prácticamente todos los productos se
tienen que importar desde muy lejos todo
esto significa que absolutamente todo en
este país es ridículamente que en otras
palabras alaska es el último lugar donde
nadie viviría quiero decir imaginad que
fuerais un millonario y pudierais vivir
donde quisierais de verdad os mudáis
alaska pues tal vez si alaska es el
quinto estado de eeuu en población
millonaria el 6,75 por ciento de su
población son técnicamente millonarios
[Música]
su pib per cápita es el séptimo más alto
de todo el país 73 mil dólares y todos
los años los alaskeños reciben un cheque
del estado sólo por vivir ahí y os
preguntaréis pero porque alaska es tan
increíblemente rico la respuesta se
puede resumir en una palabra petróleo
bar ya lo sé seguro que nadie se lo
había esperado el zumo de dinosaurio ha
convertido a alaska en la noruega de los
v6 pero si seguir visual político con
regularidad ya sabéis que vivir del
petróleo en tiempos de el coronavirus no
es un buen negocio atentos
[Música]
al ska encara un triple golpe del
coronavirus debido a su dependencia del
petróleo la pesca y el turismo os lo
hemos dicho un millón de veces por aquí
en visual político los recursos
naturales suelen ser más una maldición
que una ventaja y alaska no es que tenga
un problema de dependencia del petróleo
podemos hablar directamente de adicción
así que en cuanto a los precios del
petróleo caen los alaskeños sufren más
que nadie y todo esto explica que desde
el año 2014 alaska esté en recesión
tal cual como lo oís mientras eeuu ha
estado experimentando un auténtico boom
económico el teide de alaska no ha
dejado de caer y ahora con la pandemia
del coronavirus las cosas van de mal en
peor pero la pregunta es cómo de mal de
verdad la vida en alaska es tan terrible
porque a las que es tan rica y porque
ahora están sufriendo una recesión hay
alguna forma de acabar con el déficit de
su estado hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
destino manifiesto durante toda la
segunda guerra mundial sólo hubo una
batalla en suelo estadounidense si no
contamos con el ataque a pearl harbor
claro que no adivináis donde pues se fue
en la batalla de atún en alaska los
japoneses entendieron la importancia
estratégica de alaska y por eso
invadieron parte de ella durante un año
con esto ya nos podemos hacer una idea
de lo importante que es este estado pese
a que este donde cristo perdió las
zapatillas
en el año 1867 eeuu compro alaska por 72
millones de dólares toda una ganga oiga
básicamente pagaron 2 céntimos de dólar
por acre por aquel entonces alaska era
una colonia rusa pero en realidad ningún
ruso vivía por ahí la población de este
terreno eran prácticamente en su
totalidad y nuits y aquí hago un
paréntesis los inuits son lo que
comúnmente llamamos esquimales pero el
término esquimal es extremadamente
ofensivo así que ya lo sabéis por si un
día os encontráis con uno y diréis para
que quería eeuu comprarse alaska en su
momento este acuerdo fue muy polémico
pero enseguida se recuperó la inversión
en el año 1900 miles de estadounidenses
emigraron a estas tierras en lo que se
conoció como la fiebre del oro
tras la segunda guerra mundial el
ejército del aire- estableció bases por
todo el estado creando más puestos de
trabajo y más oportunidades para más
estadounidenses que hicieron de este
lugar su casa pensadlo bien
alaska está al lado de rusia y esto era
importante durante la guerra fría sin
embargo el auténtico despegue económico
de alaska llegó en los años 60
[Música]
en 1959 alaska se convirtió en el 49º
estado de la unión en ese momento ya
tenían más de 222 mil habitantes que era
tres veces más de lo que tenían en 1940
pero en 1968 descubrieron enormes
yacimientos de petróleo sin embargo la
fiebre del oro negro no llegó hasta unos
años más tarde pensadlo bien el petróleo
de alaska no estaba precisamente en una
zona cómoda y accesible estaba en la
zona al norte justo donde está la ciudad
de barrow y para hacer llegar todo ese
zumo de dinosaurio al resto del país
hacía falta construir una línea ducto de
1300 kilómetros he echado un vistazo a
este mar
[Música]
en otras palabras que en un principio el
petróleo de alaska era de todo menos
rentable hasta que un día las cosas
cambiaron
exacto en el año 1973 las
petromonarquías declararon un embargo de
petróleo de repente los costes del crudo
se dispararon y de repente lo que
parecía una obra faraónica se convirtió
en una necesidad bastaron dos años para
que eeuu construyera el oleoducto de
principio a fin y esto nos lleva de
vuelta a pago
[Música]
barrow es la ciudad donde se descubrió
el mayor yacimiento de petróleo no
convencional de toda norteamérica así
que ya sabéis porque hay 5000 personas
viviendo en este pueblo en realidad
alaska es un territorio lleno de
recursos naturales petróleo gas metales
preciosos bosques potencial para
energías renovables y pescados
[Música]
la industria del pescado no es cosa de
broma solo entre 2017 y 2018 alaska
proceso más de 2 millones y medio de
toneladas de pescado hablamos de una
industria de 5600 millones de dólares
que emplea a 60.000 personas de hecho
uno de cada dos pescados que se comen en
todo eeuu viene de alaska alaska también
es uno de los lugares con más
millonarios de todo eeuu en otras
palabras que podríamos decir que alaska
es la noruega de eeuu ambos tienen una
economía basada en petróleo y pescado
ambos están en el norte y ambos son muy
ricos sin embargo hay una diferencia la
economía de noruega crece de forma
estable mientras que a las que está en
una terrible recesión y diréis por qué
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuando el petróleo ya no paga las
facturas si hay un estado con problemas
ese es sin duda alguna alaska de entrada
tiene un problema de aislamiento que
sube los costes de cualquier cosa coches
medicinas comida cualquier cosa es más
cara en alaska incluso la capital del
estado
you no está aislada del resto del estado
es decir que no tiene carreteras que la
conecten con ninguna otra ciudad así que
la única forma de llegar es mediante
aviones o mediante barcos
[Música]
desde el punto de vista de los servicios
públicos a las que es una auténtica
pesadilla un estado del tamaño de libia
pero con la población de frankfurt la
densidad de población es terriblemente
bajo y precisamente por estas razones
los más caños no pagan impuestos
estatales tal vez esta sea la razón por
la que tantos millonarios viven por aquí
y diréis si no cobran impuestos cómo se
financia el estado la respuesta es el
petróleo y los recursos naturales casi
todos los ingresos del estado vienen de
los royalties que cobran por explotar
los recursos naturales y de los
impuestos a las grandes empresas y
diréis pues oye no suena tan mal solo
pagan impuestos las grandes petroleras
fantástico verdad bueno no exactamente
atentos a esta noticia
en la producción de petróleo de la costa
norte de alaska tendrá su año fiscal más
bajo desde que comenzó el oleoducto
exacto el boom del petróleo de alaska ha
terminado en realidad ahora mismo se
saca el petróleo justo y necesario para
evitar que todo el sistema de oleoducto
se congele y esto ha ocurrido por una
combinación de factores el primero es la
competencia es decir alaska no es el
único estado con petróleo otros estados
como texas o las dos dakotas también han
tenido sus fiebres del oro negro
recientemente y estos estados tienen la
ventaja de no estar en el ártico lo que
significa que no es necesario enviar a
trabajadores al fin del mundo ni tampoco
enviarlo a través de un oleoducto de
1300 kilómetros
además el barril a las que no es uno de
los más caros de extraer para que las
casas que un beneficio de su barril el
precio tiene que estar por encima de los
59 dólares
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea en el
momento en el que hacemos este vídeo el
barril de brent está en 59 con 89
dólares pero hay a gastar mucho más bajo
y todo esto explica por qué la caída de
precios del año 2014 tuvo un efecto tan
dramático en la economía de alaska
mientras el resto del país estaba
creciendo a ritmos del 2,5 por ciento
del pib
alaska empezaba su super recesión su pib
e cayó al 15 % ese año pero es que en
2015 cayó al 8% y todo esto significa
que el gobierno tenía un grave problema
recordáis que os he dicho que casi todos
los ingresos del estado vienen de los
royalties y los impuestos sobre los
beneficios de las empresas pues adivinar
lo que pasa cuando las empresas
petroleras que son las más importantes
de la zona dejan de tener beneficios de
un día para otro los ingresos del estado
cayeron en un 80 por ciento y si esto es
lo que pasó en 2014 imaginad lo que ha
ocurrido durante la pandemia del
coronavirus
el presupuesto de alaska apunta al
debate sobre los cheques de riqueza
petrolera a todo esto hay que añadirle
el hecho de que alaska se está quedando
sin petróleo se estima que este estado
ya ha extraído el 60 por ciento de sus
reservas eso explica por qué algunas
petroleras como conocophillips están
cortando gas personal hasta por más de
500 millones de dólares pero esperad un
momento porque los problemas nunca
vienen solos alaska es también una de
las regiones más afectadas por el cambio
climático que el ártico se está
calentando dos veces más rápido que el
resto del mundo todo esto implica que la
acidificación del océano también puede
dar al traste con la única industria que
todavía funciona por estos lares la
pesca
[Música]
así que toda esa riqueza de alaska
podría desvanecerse más pronto que
tarde' y la pregunta ahora es qué pueden
hacer para evitar el desastre pues ahora
mismo no vamos a ver
dividendo a las que no a las que tiene
un problema presupuestario de
proporciones your dianas esa no lo
habéis visto venir verdad el petróleo ya
no da dinero de hecho cada vez están
produciendo menos barriles
eso significa que prácticamente nadie
paga impuestos y los ciudadanos están
marchando en otras palabras que si eres
mike dunleavy el actual gobernador de
alaska y estás viendo este vídeo sólo
puedo decirte una cosa lo siento
durante décadas a las que construía un
montón de infraestructuras y proyectos
comunitarios mientras el precio del
petróleo era alto cuando era bajo
cortaba el gasto y cerraba edificios
esta vez los precios no han subido y
tras años de cortar gastos y consumir
los ahorros los líderes del estado
tienen que tomar decisiones duras y
diréis pero que pueden hacer en el
gobierno de alaska pues atentos porque
existe una solución
durante todo este vídeo hemos comparado
alaska con noruega pues bien hay otra
cosa que tienen en común ambos tienen un
fondo de inversión soberano
brains en 1976 durante el gran boom del
petróleo alasqueño el estado creó el
fondo permanente de alaska financiado
con todo el dinero que llegaba del
petróleo y el gas este fondo de
inversión está gestionado por una
empresa pública ahora bien hay una
diferencia el fondo soberano noruego
sirve principalmente para pagar las
pensiones mientras que el fondo a las
que no sirve para
pues nadie lo sabe muy bien pues bien
eso de tener un fondo de inversión
soberano que no financia a ningún
servicio público no es tan mala idea
como parece
[Música]
desde el año 1982 todos los ciudadanos
de alaska cobran el dividendo del fondo
permanente es decir que sólo por vivir
en alaska el estado te da dinero y os
parece y os preguntaréis pero de cuánto
dinero hablamos pues hasta el año 2008
los a las niñas cobraban unos dos mil
dólares al año se estima que este
dividendo ha servido para sacar a entre
15.000 y 25.000 alaskeños de la pobreza
así que aunque en alaska tengan una
crisis gigantesca el fondo ha servido
para evitar que se generen bolsas de
pobreza y diréis pero como de grandes
este fondo pues hablamos de más de 60
mil millones de dólares y por eso ahora
el gobierno está empezando a pensar que
tal vez ese dinero se pueda utilizar
para tapar todos los agujeros del estado
atentos
alaska que dependía profundamente de los
ingresos de las actividades petroleras
tuvo que lidiar con problemas fiscales
repentinos echando mano de sus ahorros y
cortando el gasto todavía tiene un
déficit presupuestario de 2.500 millones
de dólares para el año que viene
alaska ya ha reducido el gasto público
al mínimo pero todavía necesita reducir
más y no parece que el dinero del
petróleo vaya a volver por supuesto
podrían crear nuevos impuestos pero eso
sería una medida muy impopular así que
sólo parece que exista una solución
sería usar los dividendos del fondo
soberano es decir algunos legisladores
quieren usar un porcentaje de los
dividendos del fondo para financiar al
estado podría entenderse como las
comisiones que te cobraría cualquier
fondo de inversión comercial pero en
este caso serviría para financiar el
estado de alaska y os preguntaréis
bastaría con esto para resolver la
crisis fiscal de alaska y la respuesta
es física
[Música]
la empresa pública que ha gestionado
este fondo es un trabajo fantástico
tienen una cartera muy diversificada con
inversiones conservadoras y un proceso
de deliberación muy cuidadoso para que
os hagáis una idea a finales de 2016 el
fondo estaba valorado en 55 mil millones
de dólares ahora cinco años después ha
crecido hasta ponerse en los 67 mil
millones es decir que si el fondo puede
ser más que suficiente para tapar todos
los agujeros del estado e incluso dejar
las cuentas en soberano
sin embargo esto solo es una solución
temporal por supuesto con esta
estrategia alaska puede cubrir su crisis
fiscal pero no su crisis económica
durante décadas casi toda la economía de
alaska dependía del petróleo pero ahora
necesitan diversificar y atraer nuevas
industrias así que ahora la pregunta es
para vosotros creéis que alaska
terminará usando su fondo soberano para
financiar su estado podrá alaska
diversificar su economía e industrias
creéis que podrían establecerse en este
lugar podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios y como siempre no
olvidéis que aquí en visual politics
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribirse al canal y darle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]